this video was made possible by
skillshare learn new skills that you can
use at home
work or school with a free trial of
skillshare premium at the link in the
description
normal times in business are like a road
for the most part competitors are all
heading in the same direction
and while some might turn away and try a
different path
for the most part the only way to get
ahead is through brute
force to slowly catch up and take the
lead
that is difficult abnormal times in
business though
when an industry is in crisis are like a
fork in the road
the competitors all reach it together
and are forced
to pick a path this levels the playing
field
well the big players have the resources
to evaluate the different paths and
might have experience from times when
this has happened before
all companies big and small must pick a
path
and at the end of the day only one is
going to work
best crisis can be an equalizer
it stress tests the big incumbent firms
to see if they're still the strongest or
riding on inertia
and gives smaller players the
opportunity to make bold choices
that could put them ahead this is what's
happening
in the airline industry right now it's
one of the clusters of companies that
as a result of the coronavirus pandemic
had to almost
entirely shut down and is now in the
process of turning back
on and reinventing itself to capture a
new set of consumers
with new needs and wants industry
turmoil
is happening and that means that there's
a case to be made
that we're at that fork in the road that
all airlines are having to pick a path
and that this could lead to a shuffling
of the rank and order of the industry
there's a case to be made that right now
for the first time
in a long time there's real opportunity
for something
new there's opportunity for airline
entrepreneurship
if you were tasked with starting an
accounting business or
a coffee shop or a landscaping business
you'd probably know roughly what you
needed to do to start
you need to get a license or a retail
space or some lawn mowers
and with enough initiative and a little
bit of luck you'd probably even have a
real shot at successfully starting any
one of these
meanwhile if you were tasked with
starting an airline
you and i both know that no matter your
luck or initiative
you'd have almost no shot of ever taking
off due to its complexity and capital
intensity
successful airline entrepreneurship is
one of the most difficult endeavors in
business
but it is something that occasionally
real people
actually do so what does it take
what is step one of forming a new
airline
well first an airline needs a business
model
now everything for startup airlines
nowadays builds off of what makes them
unique
and new airlines have to be unique you
see
fundamentally for a new company to
succeed they need to do
something better than their competitors
they need to be cheaper
faster more convenient or just do
something that others do not
if they don't then why would customers
choose to switch to them
the competitive advantage of major
airlines is that they
are major is that you can get on one of
their planes on one side of the world
and after a few connections get off on
the other
the problem is that almost all of the
major full-service network carriers
as those in the industry will call them
were formed in the early days of
commercial aviation
and grew as the industry did today it
would just be effectively
impossible for an airline to launch with
enough scale to compete directly with
united british airways or singapore
airlines
and if they didn't the legacy airlines
would crush them
faster than they could get to the
necessary scale for their competitive
advantage to be considered their size
of the 10 largest airlines in the u.s
none
were founded in the current century and
in europe only one was
whiz air which nobody would consider a
full-service network carrier
in fact globally one of the only
examples of a full-service network
carrier established within the past few
decades without government support
is virgin australia and in their case it
was almost
by accident the collapse of ansel
australia
which was the country's only major
full-service network carrier at the time
left a massive void in australia's
aviation market
only a year into virgin australia's
operations which gave the company the
opportunity to grow
quite quickly and effectively however
even
this example gives further credence to
the theory that it's nearly impossible
for a new major full-service network
carrier to emerge in the 21st century
as virgin australia entered
administration in 2020
and is now exiting as a smaller
primarily domestic airline
seating the international market to its
legacy competitor qantas
so once again new airlines need a strong
defined and unique business model to
succeed
looking at three of the most promising
startup airlines planned to launch in
a strong defined and unique business
model
is exactly what each of them has flypop
for example
is planning to launch long-haul low-cost
flights from the uk
to secondary cities in india without
existing non-stop service such as
amritsar and ahmedabad in order to cater
to the indian diaspora living in the uk
meanwhile play airlines is looking to
reprise the business model of now
defunct wow air
and was even founded by former wow
executives by focusing on facilitating
low-cost transatlantic travel with
connecting itineraries through iceland
then in what is likely the most
promising airline startup of 2021 as its
founder previously launched westjet azul
airways and jetblue
breeze airways is looking to launch what
they refer to as hub-busting flights
on under-served routes in the u.s
meaning they're identifying routes
without existing non-stop service such
as tulsa new york or louisville to los
angeles
and capturing demand by setting up
non-stop service
crucially each of these three business
models do not involve directly competing
with full-service network carriers
budget airlines like play airlines and
fly pop tend to expand the pie by
offering prices that stimulate demand
from a lower market segment that likely
would not regularly fly on a full
service network carrier
while breeze airways will likely most
directly compete with southwest
as it's the primary incumbent airline
that might offer non-stop hub-busting
flights
in the selection of a business model not
competing against the world's largest
airlines
is a good choice because full-service
network carriers have the time and money
to start
and win a price war while startup
airlines
do not that's because it's very
difficult for startup airlines to get
funding there just isn't the appetite
for it
because the airline industry has very
little upside
for investors it goes through massive
dramatic cycles of profit and loss
depending on oil prices and external
economic conditions
but even in the best of times it makes a
very thin
profit over the past 25 years even
before the chronovirus pandemic
the industry has hovered around a four
to five percent operating margin
investors could just as easily put their
money into something more secure like
the railroad industry
which hovers between a 25 and 30 percent
operating margin
in fact that's exactly what investor
warren buffett has done
he's famously shirked significant
investments in airlines
while taking massive successful bets on
the american railroad industry
for this reason many startup airlines
fail before launch simply because they
cannot secure funding
or after launch because they didn't
secure enough funding to reach critical
mass
for those three most promising startup
airlines of 2021 though
they each have seemingly found enough
money to launch
play airlines secured a 42 million
dollar investment from avianta capital
which is an irish investment fund run by
aslan whitley ryan
a member of an influential aviation
family which includes the founders of
ryanair
meanwhile flypop's exact investor makeup
is less clear but their largest source
of funding is coming from a uk
government fund intended to kickstart
innovative businesses whose launch was
affected by kovid
finally breeze took the most traditional
funding path
having raised 83.3 million dollars
through the venture capital industry but
that was likely only possible due to its
founders remarkably consistent track
record
of successful airline startups the only
consistency with startup airline funding
is inconsistency unlike other industries
where there is often a defined ecosystem
of investors
willing and sometimes competing to fund
startups with a strong business model
plan
executive team and proof of concept you
just don't have that
with airlines the tiny number of new
entrants
plus the general lack of appetite from
investors means that finding funding to
complete the extraordinarily expensive
tasks required to set up an airline is
itself
the task that prevents most from
reaching takeoff
one of those extraordinarily expensive
tasks involves quite simply gaining the
legal right to operate an airline
every national aviation authority issues
what are typically called
air operator certificates which allows a
company to use their aircraft for
commercial purposes
in the u.s there are essentially two
choices of certificate type for
scheduled airlines
the first and simpler one is a part 135
certificate
referring to the section of the us's
federal aviation regulations that
outline this certificate's operating
requirements
now a part 135 certificate is primarily
used for cargo
and passenger charter operations which
often includes private jet operations
but it can also be used for certain
scheduled operations
specifically this certificate only
allows the use of aircraft with nine
passenger seats or fewer on scheduled
operations
with a few exceptions one of the largest
part 135 scheduled airlines in the us
for example
is cape air which operates a fleet of 94
nine-seat aircraft to primarily small
government subsidized destinations
around the us and caribbean because they
are on a part 135 certificate
they can do things like operate flights
with a single pilot even though
in practice most of their flights
operate with two pilots whereas a part
121 certificate holder like united
airlines for example would need two
pilots even to operate the exact same
aircraft on the exact
same route in general the regulations
for part 135 operations
are slightly less stringent and that
also means that attaining this license
is a lot easier costs apparently average
between 35
and 95 000 in legal fees plus an
additional 50 000
in expenses to attain a part 135
certificate
meanwhile getting a part 121 air
operator certificate
is much much more difficult these are
the certificates held by united
american airlines delta and any other
large commercial airline in the u.s
and the process to attain one is so
complicated that it's essentially
impossible without hiring a third party
consultancy to assist
this in and of itself is such a niche
process
that there are only six faa endorsed
part 121 certification consultancies in
existence after all
there are only 104 active part 121
airlines in the u.s
so a new certification is a fairly rare
occurrence
while none of the faa endorsed
certification consultancies publicized
prices
a non-endorsed competitor lists their
consulting fee as 1.2 million dollars
which includes things like creating an
operations manual training management
setting up electronic flight backs
establishing a drug and alcohol testing
program and almost
everything else needed prior to
application plus the management of the
process of actually applying itself
in general the reason this application
process is so strenuous
is because a startup airline must set up
the internal infrastructure for all the
extensive safety programs needed to pass
the faa's review
and then it must present a massive
packet of documents
proving that it has done all these
things
given the complexity of this process
some airlines decide to purchase
rather than apply for an air operator
certificate
this is what brees airways initially
planned to do
in july they applied for the u.s
department of transportation to transfer
the certificate
of now-defunct compass airlines to them
but they eventually dropped this plan
due to pushback from other airlines and
compasses pilots union
now breeze is going through the process
of applying for its own error operator
certificate
but it goes to show that buying an
existing one is a
very real possibility and it's something
that happens fairly frequently with part
135 certificates
in fact there are even websites listing
small
part 135 airlines for sale which can be
bought specifically for their
certificates
around the world while each country's
exact process is different
certification is quite often a major
hurdle for a new airline
as each country's air regulator needs to
see that the startup is fit to fly
before giving them
their stamp of approval of course these
previous steps
of deciding on a business model finding
funding and attaining an air operator
certificate
have nothing to do with the most
fundamental thing an airline needs to
operate
airplanes now somewhat
counter-intuitively
acquiring airplanes is actually one of
the simpler phases
of the airline startup process the
reason why this is
is because quite often airlines don't
actually own
aircraft themselves this is part of the
reason why brees for example
can launch with only about 90 million
dollars in funding
despite the fact that a single one of
their planned flagship aircraft
the a220 300 has a list price of about
90 million dollars
rather a startup airline like breeze
tends to use
one of two techniques the first option
is to lease this works essentially like
a car release
just on a much larger scale some 50
of commercial aircraft globally are
under lease and this option is often
more popular with smaller airlines
the advantages of leasing aircraft are
straightforward
it spreads out the cost without the need
to take on debt and it reduces risk as
lease terms can be shorter than the
useful life of an aircraft and there can
be some options to return aircraft
before the end of their lease
if there's no longer the need in
addition leasing aircraft
allows airlines to get aircraft faster
aircraft manufacturers often have a
multi-year backlog
airbus for example as of december 2020
has a
7 000 aircraft order backlog meaning an
airline ordering an aircraft today
wouldn't receive it for many years
lessors often have aircraft available
within months or even weeks
making this the attractive option for
startups also
particularly nowadays kovid has made
getting an airplane on lease
easier existing airlines have been
downsizing their fleets and getting rid
of older
less fuel-efficient aircraft in the case
of american airlines in air canada
that meant retiring 20 and 14
respectively of their e-190 aircraft
it so happens that breeze is launching
with e-190 aircraft
and even though they aren't directly
leasing the retired aircraft of american
and air canada
more aircraft of a type in the
marketplace pushes prices
down there is however another mechanism
increasingly used by airlines especially
when they need to get newer aircraft for
which there isn't a large second-hand
market
breeze for example has an order with
airbus for 60 a to 2300
aircraft now this order is directly from
breeze to airbus
but brees themselves could never pay for
60 of these aircraft
therefore what they've done is before
they've even taken delivery of the first
of these aircraft
sell five of them to another company
voyager aviation holdings which is then
going to lease these aircraft
back to breeze this means breeze is
effectively getting the exact aircraft
it wants
when it wants but functionally they get
all the benefits of a lease
it's to be expected that as the delivery
dates of the rest of the airlines a220
fleet near
the airline will enter into more of
these lease-back
agreements of course this is all a
simplistic view
of the process of airline
entrepreneurship but business model
selection
funding certification and aircraft
acquisition are the four
largest hurdles and improper completion
of any one of these
is often the source of a startup
airlines eventual failure
the rest of the process from hiring
staff finding office space crafting a
marketing strategy leasing space at
airports
and much much more is much less likely
to have a dramatic impact on their odds
of success
since the era of the emergence of
low-cost airlines
there's been little successful action in
airline entrepreneurship
with a business atmosphere primed for
disruption the next few years will prove
whether it's still possible for new
airlines to succeed
or whether the industry is still locked
down by the world's
largest airlines what this video goes to
prove is that
even for the world's toughest tasks like
starting an airline
there's someone out there doing it
successfully
that's a lot of what the philosophy of
skillshare is based on
they figure that there's nobody better
to teach skills than the people who
actually use those skills
their classes of which there are
thousands are taught by real people who
actually know what they're talking about
so it's a great way to learn for anyone
who's creative and curious which i'm
sure includes all
wendover viewers whether you want to get
ahead at work
or find a new passion skillshare
certainly has a class for you
for example if you want to start out as
a youtuber you can take
the creative video storytelling and
editing making the most of stock footage
class by nikki stevens
which is a lot of what us educational
creators do we can't go to what we're
talking about most of the time
and we often can't afford to animate our
whole videos so we rely on using
existing stock footage creatively
skillshare is built to be the best place
to learn
meaning there are no ads and they're
always launching new classes
so if you have any curiosity at all in
gaining a new skill of any type
check them out with a free trial of
skillshare premium which is available to
the first 1000 people to use the link in
the description
and you'll be helping support this
channel wall your adidas